[Música]
que si el turismo puede ser un el
dinamizador de la economía sí sí lo
puede ser de hecho yo lo creo porque es
parte de la visión estratégica la visión
de mi empresa
lo bonito de todo esto es de que el
turismo puede ser aplicable a cualquier
tipo de actividad turística desde sol y
playa
también naturaleza
cultura lo acabamos de vivir
aventura esa adrenalina la visita a
fincas de café de cacao y lo que a mí me
apasiona la observación de aves
eso turismo sostenible es lo bonito
puede aplicarse a cualquier tipo de
turismo ahora bien yo quiero que ustedes
imaginen un árbol raíces frondosas
donde esas raíces para ustedes
representan lo ambiental son los tres
pilares del turismo sostenible una de
ellas el ambiente sin el ambiente sin
los ríos sin las playas sin las aves sin
nada de estos recursos naturales y
difícilmente tendríamos turismo ahora
bien cuando nosotros hacemos turismo
tratamos de que esto minimice nuestras
acciones sean lo menos posible en
degradar lo eso es parte de un turismo
sostenible el tronco de este árbol
representa la parte socio ambiental
sociocultural en donde lo que nosotros
procuramos aquí es que tratamos en la
medida de lo posible de conocer las
creencias tradiciones pero también la
parte cultura y todo esto en donde
nosotros vamos a tener una tolerancia a
este tipo de cosas el hecho que nosotros
tengamos creencias diferentes no quiere
decir que ellos están mal o que nosotros
estamos en lo cierto eso es lo bonito
del turismo sostenible la parte de
arriba la copa de este gran árbol
imaginémonos ese árbol de ceiba que es
bien bonito bien frondoso es la parte
económica siendo turismo es un negocio y
por lo tanto no estamos para que nos
miren es porque tenemos que generar
plata y ese dinero que se ha distribuido
de la manera más justa posible no
solamente que se quede en manos de un
solo prestador
el turismo sostenible representa varias
ventajas para
la empresa o un destino que aplique al
turismo sostenible yo le voy a dar
algunas ventajas la primera ventaja es
el hecho que el turismo sostenible
genera economía para distintos tipos de
servicios desde el hotel
la comida
tours
los guías que están en esos recorridos
como transporte pero van más allá de eso
les quiero compartir un dato tuvimos la
semana antepasada si no me equivoco un
grupo de 11 personas provenientes de
eeuu estos personajes estuvieron cuatro
días en la zona vinieron aquí a la ceiba
se hospedaron en la cuenca del río
cangrejal compartieron cuatro días
hicieron rafting los llevamos a las
playas de corozal vinieron aquí al
muelle a conocer la selva hicimos un
recorrido por la ciudad etcétera
etcétera
esta gente tenía contratado en su
paquete lo que nos pagaron a nosotros
fueron tres cosas el hotel que había que
pagárselo al hotel el transporte y el
guía
el resto de cosas se compartió a 21
distintos proveedores
21 distintos proveedores estamos
hablando que cuando fueron a las playas
procuramos explicarles todo el tema de
la cultura y comprar un pan de coco a
otra señora le compraron casa ve a otra
señora le compraron otro como se llaman
la tableta
compraron la comida de un restaurante
local pero también disfrutaron de la
playa también tuvieron la oportunidad de
ir al centro de la ciudad de la ceiba y
por ahí le hablamos de las baleadas
probaron las validadas hasta el puesto
de la señora que vende en la línea del
tren hasta ella es parte del turismo y
eso es lo bueno que el turismo
sostenible procuramos como les comentaba
se distribuye la parte económica de una
manera más justa
el turismo sostenible también ayuda a
que haya empleo de calidad
el turismo sostenible permite que le
demos valor a la artesanía a lo que está
hecho malo porque en otros sitios si
compramos aquello de algún sitio en
particular y porque lo nuestro no pues
yo el tema del turismo sostenible con
andamos con personas tratamos de
incentivar le que compren a los
artesanos locales que le compren a las
personas de una región en particular
contándoles la historia hay que conectar
la historia este vídeo que está aquí es
de un amigo que casualmente está en este
salón se llama volver este amigo mío
además de ser pajarero ojo no somos
pasajeros somos pajareros somos
pajareros que sucede él además de ser ya
iba a decir la palabra pajarero
él también tiene esa habilidad de pintar
él está en un grupo de comunitario de la
comunidad de el pino pues se le dijo y
le dije volver por favor luz y te quiero
llevar estos llaveros a una feria
internacional de aves en eeuu y quiero
compartir el arte a través de este
llavero y ahí está
hicimos un vídeo de cómo hacer toda esta
artesanía y miren qué interesante a la
gente cuando yo ya les estaba contando
la historia del llavero detrás de todo
esto la gente está con macanas lo tomaba
decía es que bonito es más personas que
habían venido honduras decían yo conozco
a all there no sabía que él era artista
qué bonito es conectar la parte
turística con la parte humana y por qué
no que genere economía qué bien
esta iniciativa que pareciera sencilla
afortunadamente lo tomó la organización
mundial del turismo esta iniciativa mi
empresa y la subió al portal
internacional que tiene sobre el alcance
de los objetivos de desarrollo en una de
las maneras de cómo podemos aportar a la
economía local
la otra parte bonita del turismo
sostenible es que le damos valor a esos
recursos naturales le damos valor y
creemos y nos sentimos tan orgullosos a
los que han salido fuera del país cuando
ustedes analizan y piensan nosotros
decimos realmente honduras es bien
bonito es más bonito que un montón de
lugares
pocos a veces conocen la cuenca del río
cangrejal cuantos realmente han ido y
disfrutado todo lo que ofrece este sitio
que lo tenemos a 15 minutos de la ciudad
de la ceiba del centro 15 minutos eso es
lo que hace el turismo sostenible
también que nosotros cuando vayamos a un
sitio podamos darle valor le tenemos
amor nosotros no vamos a poder y no
vamos a poder respetar algo si no lo
conocemos no lo vamos a cuidar si no lo
conocemos para ello
tenemos que conocerlo y lo lo bonito
también de esta situación es que entre
más personas hay cuidando los recursos
naturales vamos a tratar de que esto va
a ser conocido por otras generaciones
turismo somos todos turismo nos
beneficiamos todos como les comentaba
con el grupo que tuvimos desde una
gasolinera se ve se vio beneficiada es
más hasta un carwash se vio beneficiado
se vio beneficiado o el señor que vendía
una bebida que se llama calaguala no sé
cuántos de ustedes lo han probado que
también lo tienen la cuenca del río
cangrejal súper rico bien refrescante
para algunos para otros genera otro
efecto verdad pero los que somos lo que
nos gusta esto bien el lado con tus
cubitos de hielo estamos pero che que
como decimos muchos el turismo
sostenible implica eso ver como todos
nos podemos distribuir beneficiar de
mejor manera pero les voy a dar siete
tips o siete consejos ya para finalizar
7 consejitos de cómo ustedes pueden ir
abonando a esta actividad
número uno y yo creo que es algo que
tenemos que tenerlo no solamente cuando
salgamos sino que en nuestra casa
hagamos uso racional de la energía y del
agua son súper escasos como sufrimos
cuando se nos va la energía mucho como
sufrimos por ello entonces por lo tanto
debemos de hacer un uso moderado del
agua de la energía y otros elementos que
son escasos
punto número 2 tratemos en la medida de
lo posible adquirir un bote de estos un
recipiente que lo podemos estar
reutilizando cargando de agua y no estar
comprando botella tirando la botella
bolsa de agua etcétera etcétera cada vez
más hay negocios donde tienen un oasis
en donde nos permite tener
de volver a llenar perdón la botella
entonces en ese tipo de acciones podemos
ir ayudando al tema del turismo que sea
más sostenible punto número 3 y es que
si imaginamos que nos vamos a un sendero
y nos vamos todos los que estamos aquí
se imaginan ustedes que cada uno de
ustedes se lleve un recuerdito de ese
sendero una hojita no es que sólo es una
hojita una flor no mire es que sólo es
una florcita no importa
todo esto imaginémonos que cada uno de
ustedes se lleve eso vamos a dejar
pelado a que el sendero y al siguiente
grupo no va a disfrutar igual evitemos
en la medida de lo posible andar
arrancando y por lo tanto el consejo es
sigamos las instrucciones de un día
local el turismo sostenible viene y
contrata a alguien local aunque yo ande
como guía acompañante siempre contrato
un guía local para que para asegurarme
que tenga la mejor experiencia ese
visitante contratemos los guías para
algo han hecho su esfuerzo de estudiar y
demás
punto número 4 cuando nos sumerjamos
al arrecife andemos viendo aquellas
bellezas y demás lo más seguro es que
alguien se va a querer traer un abanico
de esos que son bien bonitos moraditos
así que en mi casa se vería fabuloso no
no no dejemos el coral ahí dejemos la
estrella de mar ojo con solo sacar la
estrella de mar y enseñar la estrella de
mar para la foto no es que solo es una
foto yo lo voy a tirar de nuevo fue
suficiente un par de segundos para que
se estrella de mar muera la tiramos y
murió por si no sabíamos ese dato
hablando de datos curiosos no era eso
hace que se muere esa acción de tomarnos
esa foto entonces evitemos sacar las
estrellas de mar más bonito como tengo a
mi amigo ahí llevemos un aparato de
estos o algo o simplemente llevemos las
en el recuerdo
de este tipo de figuras marinas punto
número 5
compremos productos locales vuelve a
salir miami gol de arena foto cuando
está un poquito más joven compra estos
productos hechos por estas manos estamos
ayudándole al amigo yo prefiero
comprarle a una empresa conocida a un
empresa amigo que comprarle de repente a
una cadena o algo esa es mi filosofía
porque yo estoy aportando la economía
local le estoy fortaleciendo cuántos de
ustedes no conocen emprendedores en seis
años compremos la de esa gente y si hay
que recomendarles una mejora hagamos la
no dejemos pasar la oportunidad y los
que son los emprendedores no nos
enojemos cuando nos digan una
recomendación es por nuestro bien para
mejorar que compremos hagamos uso esto
del turismo sostenible no es como ir al
supermercado y agarrar una manzana
y yo la manzana la voy a palpar de
repente le voy a ver el color y puedo de
repente sugerir o comprar un zapato el
zapato me lo voy a poner voy a caminar y
voy a decir no me aprieta y esto el
turismo sencillamente al ser un servicio
difícilmente podemos hacer eso hasta que
lo compramos hasta que lo experimentamos
sabremos si no salió bueno o malo el
paquete que compramos pero ahí es donde
está la virtud de que nosotros podemos
decidir que en la siguiente compra no
vamos a repetir esa experiencia con ese
proveedor es ahí donde nosotros
castigamos por decirlo de alguna manera
figurativa a ese tipo de empresa porque
no estás siguiendo los principios de
turismo sostenible
punto número 6 la parte de la cultura
conozcamos las tradiciones conozcamos
las creencias compartamos al final
seguramente vamos a tener mucho más en
común de lo que creemos nos vamos a
conectar eso es bonito el tema del
turismo y punto número 7 como les estaba
mencionando hace poco escojamos las
empresas que realmente respeten y
apliquen el turismo sostenible al menos
empezar no es fácil no es tarea fácil
sin embargo ustedes deciden con una
decisión con una
ir al internet decidir investigar al
facebook que nos gusta tanto preguntar
recomendaciones y demás yo ya decidí por
el turismo sostenible
y ustedes gracias
[Aplausos]